good morning you know a generation ago
millions of people around the world
understood the full extent of the danger
we faced from nuclear weapons but
unfortunately that understanding has
been lost largely whole generation has
come of age which did not live through
the Cold War and really was never taught
about these weapons and people of my age
who didn't used to know the stuff in the
past I pretty effectively erased it from
our minds so this is a wonderful
conference for bringing attention back
to this issue and I want to start this
morning by just describing what would
happen as the direct effects of a modern
nuclear war we are all familiar with the
image of Hiroshima after the nuclear
bombing there and we have to understand
this is not what the world will look
like after modern nuclear war Hiroshima
was one small bomb about 15 kilotons 15
thousand tons of TNT a modern attack on
a city like Boston would involve not one
bomb but perhaps 10 or 12 each of them
anywheres from 10 to 50 times more
powerful than the bomb that destroyed
Hiroshima it's difficult to describe 10
or 15 bombs going off all at the same
time so I'm going to use a model of a
single explosion a single twenty Megaton
bomb 20 million tons of TNT the mega
tonnage is actually a little bit bigger
wouldn't probably fall in Boston the
destruction I'm going to describe is
actually an underestimate because you
caused more damage by spreading out the
the bombs over more efficiently over a
large area but I think it gives an
adequate understanding of the magnitude
of the danger that we face so a twenty
Megaton bomb going off over the
Statehouse in downtown within one one
thousandth of a second the fireball
would form reaching out for two miles in
every direction engulfing everything
including the building we're sitting in
in a fireball which the temperatures
within this would rise to up to 20
million degrees Fahrenheit which is
hotter than the surface of the Sun and
everything would be vaporized
the building's the people the trees the
upper level of the earth itself would
disappear true distance of four miles in
every direction the blast would generate
over pressures of 25 pounds per square
inch and winds in excess of 600 miles
per hour mechanical forces of that
magnitude could destroy anything that
people can build underground shelters
collapse when they're exposed to
pressures this great to a distance of
six miles in every direction the heat
would be so intense the automobiles
would melt to a distance of ten miles in
every direction we're out now to the 128
Beltway the winds would still be greater
than 200 miles per hour the blast
pressure is still greater than 10 pounds
per square inch forces of that magnitude
will level masonry buildings wooden
frame buildings a building like this
would see the walls and the floors swept
out to be a steel skeleton left behind
to a distance of 16 miles in every
direction and note I've had to change
the scale of the map to accommodate this
zone of destruction to a distance of 16
miles in every direction the heat would
still be so intense that everything
flammable would burn paper cloth
gasoline wood heating oil plastic it
would all ignite causing hundreds of
thousands of fires which over the next
half-hour would coalesce into a
firestorm thirty-two miles across
covering over eight hundred square miles
within this entire area the temperatures
would rise to 1400 degrees Fahrenheit
all of the oxygen would be consumed and
every living thing would die the case of
Boston we're talking about something in
the order of three million people dead
in a half an hour
beyond this firestorm the destruction
would continue to a distance of 19 miles
people standing outside with septa
third-degree burns on any exposed skin
resistance of 21 miles second-degree
burns to a distance of 40 miles people
who turned reflex ly to look at the
sudden flash of light would be blinded
there would be hundreds of thousands of
casualties all kinds of injuries people
blinded as I mentioned people made death
by having their eardrums ruptured people
suffering penetrating wounds as shards
of glass flew through the air people
with with mechanical injuries and crush
injuries from being thrown themselves
through the air or being trapped under
collapsing buildings and most especially
there would be people with burns tens if
not hundreds of thousands of people with
major burn injuries they would all need
urgent medical attention and that care
would not be available in the entire
United States there are about 2,000 burn
beds here in the Boston area there are
three institutions between them 46 burn
beds for hundreds of thousands of
patients and all three of these
facilities are in the zone of complete
destruction in fact almost all of the
hospitals in metropolitan area would be
destroyed most of the doctors would be
dead most of the nurses would be dead
there'd be no electricity to power EKG
machines x-ray machines what little
supplies were not destroyed blood
products antibiotics pain medicine we be
used up in the first minutes of dealing
with this catastrophe there be no EMS
system to transport people to hospitals
and in fact the vast majority of the
people who were injured would also die
and if this attack were part of a
large-scale war between the United
States and Russia this same level of
destruction would be visited on every
major city in both countries a study
which would published in 2002 showed
that if only 300 of the 1,500 warheads
that the Russians maintain on here
trigger alert hit urban targets in the
United States 75 to 100 million people
would be dead in the first half hour
in addition the entire economic
infrastructure of the country would be
destroyed all the things that we depend
on to maintain our population
we're not hunter-gatherers or
subsistence farmers we need an intact
society to live and that society would
be gone the internet would be gone
the electric grid the public health
system the food distribution system none
of this would exist anymore
and it is probable that in the months
following this nuclear war the vast
majority of the American and Russian
people who did not die in the initial
attack wit also died from exposure from
starvation from radiation poisoning from
epidemic illness all told perhaps a half
a million people half a billion people
rounded and as my colleague professor
Roebuck will explain in his talk these
direct effects are only a part and
incredibly enough only a small part of
the damage that we caused by a nuclear
war so why talk about this well for two
reasons first because if we do not take
action this is the future that will be
this is going to happen we've been told
for 25 years that we don't need to worry
about nuclear war between the United
States and Russia well even during that
period we knew that there could be an
accident and there have been at least
five occasions since the early 1980s
when either Moscow or Washington
prepared to launch nuclear war than the
mistaken belief that it was already
under attack but in the last two or
three years we've also come to
understand that the assurances we
received that deliberate nuclear war
between the US and Russia was impossible
those assurances were hollow the crisis
in Ukraine has made it clear that the
United States and Russia could end up on
opposite sides of a military conflict
and since that crisis began there's been
unbelievable nuclear saber-rattling on
both sides
the Russians have threatened repeatedly
to use nuclear weapons in response to
this crisis and NATO for its part it's
conducted military exercises very close
to Russian borders using nuclear capable
forces it is an extremely dangerous
situation and has led leaders on both
sides
to warn that the danger of nuclear war
today is greater than at any time in the
past greater than it was during the
1980s that's one reason why we need to
talk about this the other and more
important reason is that this is not the
future that must be we don't have to go
down this route nuclear weapons are not
a force of nature they're not an act of
God we've built them with our own hands
and we know how to take them apart all
that has been missing is the political
will to do this unfortunately over the
last few years a new powerful
international movement has developed
calling for the stigmatization
prohibition and abolition of nuclear
weapons it's led excuse-me by the
countries which do not currently have
nuclear weapons the non-nuclear weapon
states which have come to understand
that they cannot rely on the United
States and the other nuclear powers to
meet their obligations under article 6
of the NPT that they the non-nuclear
weapon states have to provide leadership
they have come together in a series of
three very important intergovernmental
conferences the last of which was
attended by a hundred and fifty-eight
nations government conferences to
discuss just this kind of information
what is going to happen if there
actually is a nuclear war and all three
of these conferences have concluded with
the obvious understanding that these
weapons must be eliminated before
they're used at the United Nations last
fall 130 plus countries voted to
establish what was called a noted
working group to address the current gap
in international law which does not yet
prohibit possession of these weapons
that open-ended working group is meeting
in Geneva that had its first session in
February they will convene again in May
and it is probable that it will
recommend to the General Assembly this
fall a new treaty banning the possession
of nuclear weapons defining their
possession to be illegal something which
can change the entire tone of the
international conversation about nuclear
weapons and put unprecedented pressure
on the nuclear weapons States to live up
to their obligations under Article six
and to sit down and negotiate a real
binding nuclear weapons convention
for the detailed steps to eliminate
these Arsenal's this is an extraordinary
opportunity unfortunately here in the
United States there's been almost a
blackout about this process there's been
very little attention paid to it and
that becomes I think our job to figure
out how to build support for this
international movement and how to take
advantage of this international movement
to put pressure on our government to
meet its obligations and to eliminate
its nuclear arsenal this is a tremendous
responsibility it is a huge burden that
sits on our shoulders we are literally
responsible for the fate of the earth
but if this is a great burden I think it
is also something of a gift that has
been given to us every one of us wants
to do something good with our life we
have been given the opportunity to save
the world and that is a very good thing
to do it says in Deuteronomy it's
reported in Deuteronomy that God said
behold I put before you life and death
therefore choose life that you and your
children might live that is literally
the choice before us today before all of
humanity and so let us in our work today
dedicate ourselves to choosing wisely
and to acting with courage and
determination so that indeed our
children might live I want to thank you
for coming to this meeting this morning
this is a difficult topic to talk about
it's a difficult way to spend today but
even more I want to thank you for the
work which I know you're going to do
after today no one of us is expected to
do this job all by herself but every one
of us is expected to do that part of the
job which falls to us to do and that is
our individual responsibility in this
situation thank you very much
Red's
late
it'll be great if we were able to get
more films especially popular films
about this subject I think the reason
why these weapons still exist is
threefold first of all people don't know
that don't believe that this can really
happen and secondly they don't believe
they don't understand